Why Some Countries Drive on the Right and
Some on the Left
Have you ever wondered why some countries
drive on the left and others on the right?
Well, wonder no more.
The origin of this practice varies based on
the time period and country, but primarily,
throughout history, people used the “keep-left”
rule.
Only very recently did the world predominately
switch to “keep-right”.
The first real archaeological evidence of
a keep-left or keep-right type rule for a
road originates in the Roman Empire, which
shouldn’t be surprising as they built a
lot of massive, well-trafficked roads spanning
Europe and thus would have needed to establish
certain rules governing how people were to
interact on the roads.
So which side did the Romans use?
Archaeological evidence suggests it was common
for the Romans to drive on the left side of
the road.
One confirmation of this was discovered in
1998 where a Roman quarry in Swindon, England,
had grooves in the road going away from the
quarry on the left side that were significantly
deeper than those on the right, due to the
added weight of the stone.
It is not precisely known why they would have
chosen this side, but it is probably similar
to one of the main reasons this practice continued
into the Middle Ages.
During the Middle Ages, the roads weren’t
always very safe for travelers; meeting people
coming the other way on the road was something
best done defensively.
From this, many historians believe the keep-left
rule was adopted because, on a horse, if you
were right-handed and you met some unsavory
company on the road, you could draw your weapon,
typically attached to your left side, with
your right hand and bring it to bear quickly
against the person who is going the opposite
way of you on your right; all the while, controlling
the reigns with your left hand.
Then of course, if you happened to meet a
friend on the road, you could more easily
offer your right hand in greeting without
needing to reach across your body when on
horseback.
Back then, people on horseback typically ruled
the road, so everybody else followed suit.
This keep-left rule was so common that in
1300 AD Pope Boniface VIII decreed that all
pilgrims headed to Rome, from wherever they
were coming from, should abide by the keep-left
rule of the road along their journey.
This held across most of the Western World
until the late 1700s.
The switch to the keep-right rule occurred
in the eighteenth century when teamsters in
the United States would drive large wagons
with a team of horses, as the name implies.
These wagons tended to dominate the streets
and forced everybody else to abide by the
rule of the road the teamsters were using.
Very importantly, in many of those old, large
American wagons, they did not include a seat
on the wagon for the driver.
Rather, the driver would typically sit on
the rear left most horse, when the driver
was right-handed.
This allowed him to easily drive a whole team
of horses with a lash in his right hand.
This forced the issue of having oncoming traffic
on your left as the drivers would want to
make sure that no part of their team or wagon
collided with oncoming traffic.
When sitting on the rear left-most horse,
this was much easier to do when using a keep-right
rule of the road.
Gradually, this system spread so that by the
late eighteenth century, the first laws concerning
this in the United States were passed, starting
in 1792 in Pennsylvania, where the rule of
the road was now officially a keep-right rule.
This quickly spread throughout the United
States and Canada.
So how did this spread through Europe?
It started with France.
The reasons why the French switched to a keep-right
rule instead of the traditional keep-left
rule aren’t completely clear.
Some say it is because the French Revolutionists
didn’t want anything to do with something
that a Pope had decreed.
Others say it was because they didn’t want
to use the same rule of the road the English
used.
Still others say it was entirely Napoleon’s
doing.
The reasons why he may have done this, if
that is the case, are even more a matter of
pure speculation.
Whatever the real reason, France switched
to the keep-right system.
Napoleon spread this system throughout the
countries he conquered.
Even after he was defeated, most of the countries
he had conquered chose to continue with the
keep-right system.
The most important of these countries, as
far as eventually further spreading the keep-right
system, was Germany.
Fast forward to the twentieth century and,
as Germany conquered countries in Europe,
they forced their keep-right system onto those
countries.
England never adopted this method primarily
because massive wagons, as became common in
the United States, didn’t work well on narrow
streets, which were common in London and other
major English cities.
England was also never conquered by Napoleon
or later Germany.
Thus, they kept the classic keep-left rule
of the road that had endured for hundreds
of years before.
By 1756, this “keep left” rule was made
an official law in Britain, originally referring
to protocols when traveling over the London
Bridge.
As the British Empire expanded, this keep-left
rule, as a law, also spread somewhat.
This hasn’t endured in most of the former
British ruled countries, primarily thanks
to Germany and the growing popularity of the
keep-right system.
There are still a few holdouts though, probably
the largest of which, by population, is India.
Although, if you’ve ever driven in most
regions of India, you’ll know that any supposed
“rules” of the road are more just extremely
loosely followed guidelines.